la trinité du jour c'est karine le
marchand a plein
lalala lalala lalala 6 mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ça et je savais que
j'avais un prétendant zapper mouches
avec du vinaigre vous soyez venu en
jogging
il aurait pu exciter aussi j'aimerais
qu'on revienne car ils surent voilà ce
week-end on a vu des photos de vous dans
ces colonnes d'un magazine people
voilà vous à les rassurer christophe
carrière on vous a vu aux côtés d'harry
habitants voilà est-ce que c'est vrai ou
pas cette histoire mais j'ai supplié
veut pas de moi non c'est le film senna
c'est un ami mais je mets mes mails est
très beau mais il n'y a pas eu bisous
câlins et des bisous bologhine c'est
vrai qu'à un moment on a on a beaucoup
parlé de cette histoire un match avec
lilian thuram à l'arche où c'est vrai
qu'il fait très chaud sur le plateau
c'est vous voulez qu'on reparle monsieur
je me suis jamais exprimé un mois c'est
ça vous êtes jeu m'exprimer là dessus
pourquoi parce que j'estime que j'ai
l'intimé conviction que de faire du mal
ou dire du mal d'une personne avec
laquelle on a vécu sept ans d'amour dont
on a élevé les enfants c'est se faire du
mal à soi même d'accord donc et je
dirais je n'irai pas dans cette
indignité là je n'ai jamais je les ai
toujours défendu et je défendrai
toujours publiquement il ya un truc qui
keating qui vous a marqué c'est que vous
avez reçu une invitation du grand
journal pour le lendemain donc de
l'apparition de lilian thuram donc
c'était jeudi et vous inviter pour le
vendredi j'ai alors que j'y serai alors
que jeudi matin quand le jour
effectivement où il est passé au grand
journal
donc passé le soir lui à l'accord ils
m'ont invité on ne le dirait pas
rédacteur en chef m'envoyer un texto
genre de métier des textos déjà en me
disant voilà
nous antoine de caunes vous invite
demain en réaction à ce qui va être dit
ce soir d'accord ça veut dire que déjà
dès 9 heures du matin
il savait la mise en scène qu'ils
allaient faire le texto qu'ils allaient
sélectionnés qui n'avaient rien à voir
ce qui a été dit d'ailleurs son ensemble
sans me demander de vérifier l'état de
donner mon point de vue sur le texto
d'avant le texto d'après sens je sens
voilà sans vérifier les sources
et voilà et c'est la leçon était bien
apprise j'avais plus j'étais pas là mais
j'avais plus qu'à monter au bûcher de
fer action réaction c'est jerry springer
est ce qu on a tourné de faire humble et
que l'autre derrière ramène ses textos
et soit dans la même indignité essai de
la raclure de bidet pour moi même heure
alors est ce que vous appelez est ce que
vous m'avez la meuf qui fait j'ai zappé
sur une émission n'est déjà fait alors
on y va je zappe où je mate l'amour est
dans le bus mais comment vous réagissez
sur vous chez vous également un sur
twitter et sur beaucoup y en a déjà qui
ne comptent plus pêchu karine ranson
cela dit je zappe carrière on va y
revenir tout à l'heure on vous attend
parce que je sais pas ce que vous avez
trouvé comme argument alors beaucoup
zappé pourquoi mais alors là oui on me
mettait dans la brise d'habitude le je
t'aime je suis aimerait si vous
commencez à sortir des expressions de
vieux comme ça où la fraîcheur et je
comprends mais je ne suis pas très jeune
alors karine lemarchand je vous dire
c'est très sain je vous proposais des
citations
vous devrez me dire en quelques
candidats de l'amour est dans le pré il
y avait ça oui toutes les 16 purée
d'accord alors je vous dis à chaque fois
que vous n'aurez pas la bonne réponse
vous devrez faire quelque chose avec un
des chroniqueurs
amenez moi la roue des chroniqueurs s'il
te plait merci larousse et chroniqueur
la route du bonheur
merci merci
donc voilà vous avez ici donc la route
les chroniqueurs
donc à chaque fois que vous perdez vous
devez faire quelque chose avec un ami à
l'écran dycker alors pour que vous voyez
des chroniqueurs dont vous avez
christophe carrière vous avez christophe
carrelas vous avez une critique ciné
s'est incliné vous avec christophe
carrière vous avez donnée à l'express
également et christophe carrière voilà
messieurs iphone edge adam chez smile
beyond the way you lie for ipod iphone
et moi je vais vous dire elle arrive à
tout l'union sofia bul
mais là c'est encore bien fait bon alors
voilà alors attention le prochain si
vous perdez la prochaine ce sera bien
sûr le smac bien sûr attention c'est
parti
oui c'est beau ce match au sérieux
ouais
ring ce soir dans l'amour est dans tes
mots rester positif le king sérieux on
va bien tous les emplois qu'ils nous
regardent c'est rien c'est juste a dit
après ce sera quelque chose voilà mais
quand même province les poser d'autres
questions parce que je la connais bien
c'est une phrase qu'elle aurait pu
sortir lors d'un dîner un baril entre le
plat et le dessert ne s'appelle dessert
alors juste sur sept dans les justes sur
cette rumeur il fait ouais non mais
surtout juste sur le jingle l'invité est
obligée de danser un ces nouveaux donc
allons-y on y verra les meilleurs
taureaux homozygotes promettait le dj
wiwi dans sa sise à l'ats alex alors
recouvert
je dans les
du
comment tu aimais
si tu t'en
que tu joues au cap
là tout va bien
et je dis ouais tu te démerdes 1er
manche on aime dit ouais j'ai fait dix
ans de conservatoire tu m'étonnes j'ai
arrêté je pouvais être un don inné ouais
j'avais abbas colotti sait plus quoi
sortir
je suis vraiment poussé mais ils ont des
traits ce qu'on est en train de le
perdre sur quelle personnalité des huit
karine a fait une vanne ya quelques
années tout le matin à la radio
est ce que ces réponses à roselyne
bachelot b
laurence ferrari ou c'est cyril hanouna
même si ça m'étonnerait vu qu'il frise
la perfection et qu'à mes yeux il est
tout simplement intouchable
eh bien on vérifie regarder à dernière
question de karine elle est la seule
vache folle encore consommables en
france karine roselyne bachelot
jarville
il y avait plusieurs propositions à
d'accord il y avait quoi d'autre bon je
suis pas sûr